en el corazón del gran valle del rift en
kenia se encuentra el parque hell's gate
la puerta del infierno es conocido por
sus riscos y por la gran diversidad de
su fauna salvaje
pero son hombres en estas misteriosas
piedras que despiden vapor
un fenómeno natural que ha fascinado a
los geólogos
de sting y estrujar el vapor aquí es
realmente caliente más o menos 120
grados es muy caliente y proviene de
reservorios de agua que se encuentran a
unos 1000 metros de profundidad el suelo
del valle del río tiene muchas fracturas
debido a la actividad volcánica y el
calor utiliza esas fracturas como
conducto para salir a la superficie
en kenia este vapor es considerado un
tesoro nacional y un regalo de la
naturaleza se puede utilizar para
producir electricidad gracias a las
plantas energéticas la energía
geotérmica es una de las fuentes de
energía más abundantes del planeta la
segunda después de la solar pero todavía
no se ha aprovechado todo su potencial
el vapor llega desde los pozos de
extracción y después pasa a través de
esta tubería gigante
by karen kit y es un pionero de la
energía geotérmica ha trabajado como
ingeniero en esta planta durante 24 años
en total hay cinco plantas y una sexta
en construcción en conjunto producen un
tercio de la energía total que el país
necesita
esta es la sección más importante de la
planta aquí está en la turbina y el
generador
es la mejor fuente de energía y la más
barata porque es local es segura y es
ecológica
en el continente africano alrededor de
la mitad de la población no tiene acceso
a la electricidad y esta abundante
fuente de energía renovable podría ser
la solución pero kenia aún no cuenta con
el capital suficiente para comercializar
este recurso el banco europeo ha
invertido alrededor de 290 millones de
euros en el sector durante los últimos
40 años
driving
nuestra principal motivación no son sólo
los impactos climáticos y su mitigación
sino también el impacto que esto puede
tener en la vida de las personas
y es importante por los retos que europa
enfrenta la migración la resolución de
conflictos la energía es fundamental
para el desarrollo
durante la última década europa ha
invertido más de 26 mil millones de
euros en todo el continente 5 de los
cuales se han destinado a proyectos de
energía limpia dentro de unos meses la
planta estará operando a plena capacidad
y el kart ya se habrá convertido en la
planta de energía geotérmica más grande
del mundo